Here's how this
video feels to a fly.
(SPEAKING VERY SLOWLY)
Welcome to D News.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Anthony here for D News.
And you know I'm all about
how animals see the world.
In a previous video,
we talked about how
they see colors
and magnetic fields
and all kinds of insane stuff.
But now a new study in animal
behavior shows some of them
also see things in matrix
bullet time-- whoa.
The team measured a whole bunch
of animals and their reaction
times based on something
called critical flicker fusion
frequency, basically
how their body responds
to things like flashing lights.
And it turns out, the
processing of information
is tied to an animal's
size and metabolic rate.
You know how hard
it is to swat a fly?
That's because they
take in seven times more
visual and audio information
per second than we do.
The same goes for
insects and small birds.
Dogs take in information
at twice the speed we do.
That's why you can't get your
dog into TV or a Skype video.
It's just seeing this
weirdly flickering screen.
Reaction time is the difference
between life and death
in the wild, especially
for small animals
that are prey for
just about everything.
So their ability to take
in information quickly
is essential for their survival.
And you know how humans process
information is interesting.
We can only take in so much at
a time, but we can change it,
or rather, our bodies
can, situationally.
If you ever felt like
time's slowed down
before a car accident
or a particularly
dangerous situation,
that's your body
flipping your brain
into overdrive,
so you have more
ability to react.
Our ability to
process information
can also be changed
by age and training.
Athletes have a tendency
to be able to take
in more information while
playing their particular sport,
meaning time seems just
a tiny bit slower to them
during a game.
And as we get older, our
ability to process and take
in information
slows down, meaning
time seems like it's slightly
faster than we were younger.
In case you're
wondering, besides flies,
squirrels and
pigeons seem to take
in the most information at once.
The slowest animals were the
European eel, the leatherback
turtle, and the
black nose shark.
And interestingly,
only one animal's speed
doesn't match its perception.
The tiger beetle runs too fast
to keep up with its own vision.
It has to stop, wait a
second, and then run again.
It is like living in a
permanently buffering YouTube
video.
We've all been there.
Am I right?
If you want to know more
about animal vision or any
of their other
crazy abilities, we
have tons of videos about
them in the links below.
And subscribe for more D News.